that the agreements would be big and
bold our distinguished leader from the
Senate will announce how big and how
bold Thanks and what remains to be seen
is another we agreed that we would meet
again to talk about how it would be paid
for but we're very pleased with the
positive attitude toward recognizing the
trillions of dollars of need according
to the American Society of Civil
Engineers the deficit that we have in
our infrastructure and now we have an
opportunity to work together in a
bipartisan way building infrastructure
of America has never been a partisan
issue and we hope to go forward in a
very non partisan way for the future
with that I'm just pleased to yield to
the distinguished thank you and it was a
very constructive meeting it's clear
that both the White House and all of us
want to get something done on
infrastructure in a big and bold way and
there was goodwill in this meeting and
that was different than some of the
other meetings that we've had which is a
very good thing
first we agreed that infrastructure is
crucial to the future of America
we agreed it creates jobs we agreed it
keeps us competitive
we agreed that for 25 years this kind of
big bold bill that we could pass would
make America better places not just a
one-year or two-year we agreed on a
number which was very very good two
trillion dollars for infrastructure
originally we had started a little lower
even the president was eager to push it
up to two trillion dollars and that is a
very good thing and then we talked about
a number of things we would do obviously
the roads and the bridges and the
highways obviously water but also a big
emphasis on broadband that every
American home we believe needs broadband
an emphasis on the power grid so we
could bring clean energy from one end of
the country to the other and several
other issues
we told the president that we needed his
ideas on funding that the last bill he
proposed which a was smaller but be took
as much money away and the speaker
emphasized this took as much money away
as it put in wasn't going to work
so where does he propose that we can
fund this because certainly in the
Senate if we don't have him on board
it'll be very hard to get the Senate to
go along and we said we would meet in
three weeks and he would present to us
some of his ideas on funding so this was
a very very good start and we'll see we
hope it will go to a constructive
conclusion well we can obviously we are
here to do something for the American
people we have said all along in our for
the people agenda that we ran on that we
were there to lower the cost of health
care for the American people by lowering
the cost of prescription drugs and we
hope to work with the President on that
we said we're there doing lower health
care costs bigger paychecks by building
the infrastructure of America and a
green and futuristic way and we talked
about cleaner government for the first
two we think we can work with the
President on while we may have our
difficulties in other areas but we
cannot we cannot we cannot ignore the
needs of the American people as we go
forward
right after the the midterms the
president said he suggested that he
wouldn't be able to work with you we
were simultaneously investigating him if
you could sense that that has passed I
ask you what is a bigger priority for
Democrats in investigating the president
or trying to make our priority to honor
our responsibilities under the
Constitution of the United States to
meet the needs of the American people
and to honor our oath of office I'm
going to yield yeah let me just say one
more letter in previous meetings the
president has said if these
investigations continue I can't work
with you he didn't bring it up and so
we're going
I believe we can do both at once we can
come up with some good ideas on
infrastructure we want to hear his ideas
on funding that's gonna be the crucial
point in my opinion and the house and
the Senate can proceed in its oversight
responsibilities the two are not
mutually exclusive and we were glad he
didn't make it that way last question
I'll take a one from a woman
well we have a some of our members we
have our leadership there and we and I
have a rule when I go to a meeting
with a multi with many members and that
rule is the purpose of the meeting is
not to criticize the President of the
United States and secondly that every
person has a chance to say what he or
she came to say so this is a
collaborative effort and we hope it will
be very bipartisan and but we will
doesn't be meeting next about how it's
paid for and that will engage of course
the secretary of the Treasury among
others and our leadership in terms of
the ways and means and the finance that
will also spring from the committee of
jurisdiction for example the
transportation infrastructure committee
which has its own funding mechanism
questions you're asking but everybody
who is appropriate to the solution this
is the last thing we're going to say the
we agreed that the same group would meet
in about three weeks and the president
would present his ideas on funding and
we would take it from there and if we
had to break up in smaller groups after
that so we would I want you to take this
home with you because one really
important advance that we made in this
meeting was the president's real
acceptance or maybe just agreement and I
almost say acceptance because he may
have been thinking of this all along and
that is that infrastructure that
infrastructure should include a
broadband and its employed the
healthcare it's important to education
it's important to Commerce and his
embrace of that in addition to
transportation and water issues what's
doing thank you very much
[Music]